Jack thank you
it has been a long night so let's cut
past the chase to the outcome for best
picture the nominees are The Crying Game
Stephen Woolley producer
a few good men David Brown Rob Reiner
Andrew Scheinman producers
Howards End this smile merchant producer
scent of a woman Martin breasts producer
Unforgiven Clint Eastwood producer
and the Oscar for the Best Picture of
1992 goes to Clint Eastwood
mmm thank you so this is just a
wonderful one because this includes this
goes to just about everybody I can think
of and I want to thank the whole the
total crew of a thank Joe Himes and
Marko Bala and everybody who nurtured
this film the whole marketing department
at Warner Brothers in the in the year of
the woman
the greatest woman on the planet is here
tonight that's my mother Ruth
I want to thank Bob Daly and Terry Semel
the whole executive strata over there
we lost it Warner Brothers lost a great
friend and Steve Ross this year Steve
did get to see this this picture and he
predicted this outcome so I'll don't
dedicate this to Steve Ross thank you